world leaders in condemning Russia's
Invasion he has just given another
statement
dear fellow citizens
today is an awful day for Ukraine
and it's a gloomy day for Europe we are
all concerned about the peace
I can't imagine the questions you may
ask yourself tonight I feel pretty much
the same the situation is very serious
we've just seen the beginning of a war a
war that we haven't witnessed in Europe
for the last 25 years
Russia's President Putin has decided to
attack
the Ukraine in military terms that's an
attack on an independent sovereign
country
this cannot be justified by anything and
by nobody it's an attempt and shifting
borders with violent means in Europe
maybe even to eradicate a whole country
from the map of the world
deliberately Putin
violates the principles of the U.N
Charter and the European
peace order he endangers the life of
countless people in the Ukraine a sister
Nation all that happens not far away
from us here in Europe just two flight
hours serve from Berlin their families
sitting in bomb shelters women men and
children are afraid of their lives
ukrainians take to the arms to defend
their home country against an invading
Army in those difficult hours
we think of the courageous people in the
Ukraine
today the Ukrainian people and its
freely elected government have our full
solidarity this violation of the
sovereignty of Ukraine by Russia that's
something we are not going to accept the
attack on Ukraine is an attempt by
putting to turn back time but there is
no way going back to the time of the
19th century when the big Powers decided
and these small Powers had no say
there's no way back to the times of the
Cold War when the superpowers divided
the world amongst themselves and there
is no way back to the times before 1989.
at that time the citizens of Central and
Eastern Europe fought for their freedom
in democracy they did that in our
country they did that in the Ukraine and
that is why
we have always wanted Putin not to wage
war against Ukraine a week ago I
personally talked to him in the Kremlin
over 7 flowers and I told him clearly
this war would be uh bad mistake it
would also endanger the future of his
own country it would also be a damage to
his own Nation President Putin
ignored all the warnings he ignored all
attempts to find a diplomatic solution
he alone it wasn't the Russian people
who decided for that war he alone Bears
full responsibility for that that war is
Putin's War
stop fighting stop military action
please draw Russian troops from the
Ukraine
take back the recognition of luhansk
international
we have always tried to find dialogue we
have always tried to find a way to talk
to Moscow we had hope but we were not
naive and that is why in parallel to
that we prepared for this case with our
allies with our partners in the European
Union and in NATO under the G7 we have
agreed on how package of economic
sanctions our goal is to show to the
Russian government that they will pay a
high price for this aggression right
after Donetsk and Luhan Square
recognized by Russia we impose the first
sanctions and we have suspended the
certification of Nordstrom to the gas
pipeline given the current attack on
Ukraine we will place more and profound
sanctions that will hit the Russian
economy very hard we at the same time
must make sure that this conflict
doesn't spill over to other countries of
Europe
um
in agreement with our American and
European partners that we want to do
everything we can to prevent such a
situation Putin shouldn't underestimate
the natural resolution NATO resolution
to defend ourselves this goes also for
our NATO Partners in the Baltic states
in Romania Bulgaria and everywhere
Germany and its allies know how to
defend themselves
dear fellow citizens
we are resolved and we act together this
is our strength as free democracies
Putin is not going to win the citizens
in the Ukraine wants democracy they want
freedom
and Europe's future will be a future in
Freedom you can mind them and in peace
we are going to make sure this happens
together with our friends and partners
well that was that German's Chancellor
Olaf Schultz with a national address
addressing the big story of the day that
we're covering around the clock here on
Dodge Vella Russia's invasion of Ukraine
and listening to that speech is DW's
Chief political editor Michaela kufner
who's uh with us now uh welcome Michaela
so here we have a Chancellor only a few
months into his new job and then this
and pick out some of the the highlights
of that speech for us would you please
yeah he's in office for less than 80
days it took Angela Merkel almost one
and a half decades to find a crisis the
pandemic to address the Nations for Olaf
shorts he doesn't certainly he doesn't
get that 100-day grace period and has to
talk about a war he says this is
Vladimir Putin's War he vows that Putin
will not win he also promises a future
for Europe in Peace and Freedom together
with friends and allies these are
historic days these are actually
historic hours where Olaf shorts has to
stand before the nation and say that
Vladimir Putin basically rejected the
extended arm of diplomatic talks and
negotiations time and time again
himself was in Moscow last week on
Tuesday I was with him on that flight
and I saw him
um essentially try everything and not
mention the north stream 2 pipeline as
an entry ticket for talks with Vladimir
Putin only to learn today that Vladimir
Putin quite clearly already had made up
his mind to wage war to invade Ukraine
once again one has to say and now this
fully fledged war and we're already
right in the middle of the war over the
narrative on this because it's quite
striking that the West is responding
while Vladimir Putin two claims that he
himself has to respond to what he
perceives to be a threat by the west by
NATO
now Germany's economy Minister has said
that new Western sanctions will hit
Russia badly perhaps you could talk us
through what's on the table
and from the EU what exactly that next
step of punitive sanctions as it's being
put and not just by all our salts will
be we expect
the Russia essentially be to be cut off
from a lot of the cash flow of
international cash flow there but we
also heard from Germany's trade Minister
earlier today saying that these
sanctions will also hit some German
Industries this could be high-tech
Industries we heard earlier from
commission President uzler Van de lein
that the intention is to prevent the
progress the development of Russia in
the future that by clinging to the past
it is losing its prospects for a more
prosperous future there so we're still
to learn the details but this is going
to hurt not just Russia particularly
badly Germany a key trading partner here
also the German trade Minister preparing
the ground to explain to Germans why
they will feel in their pockets the fact
that Vladimir Putin has decided to
attack Ukraine yeah you bring me to my
next point because we're at a we're at a
situation where that's a situation where
um the imposition of these sanctions
going to hit the German economies you
say Russia a major trading partner but
also when it comes to power where the
Europe already seeing um major increases
in power prices and that tap from Russia
especially those sanctions uh completely
remove that that's that's going to be
cut off and and up go the prices
and that's also why the German trade
Minister was Keen to stress that energy
security was there that's also the
message we heard out of Brussels earlier
but just take a look at the markets
um the oil prices are already Rising as
we speak
um and with Germany being so highly
dependent with 40 percent of gas
supplies coming from Russia 35 of oil
supplies yes there is a great dependency
which Germany is at pains to get rid of
by mandating in the future those energy
providers the storage facilities to keep
more storage but that's all talk for the
future and yes we have the promise that
it will be enough that people won't have
to turn off their heating but people
will feel this in their pockets and that
is the explaining of German European
countries have to do to their citizens
but also the whole military aspect is
now suddenly something in this Center of
German public debate Germany is not used
to this and Germany's not used to
talking about its own security and
debating that right well we're in a new
world this morning Michaela akufner
Chief political editor thank you
so what are people saying on the streets
of Moscow well let's hear from some of
them and as you would imagine they were
mixed reactions
believe me I wouldn't want a full-scale
war in Europe or in the world I hope
that the problem will be solved soon and
there will be peace again
no one knows what's going to happen with
the currency with our economy and it's
not clear if we're able to survive the
crisis like in 2014 or our situation
will only get worse
I just want to say that this situation
makes me happy rather extremely
concerned
otherwise Ukrainian and Russian actions
seem logical from both perspectives so
it doesn't allow you to choose who's
right or wrong for me it's a brotherly
country and a brotherly people
if Putin thinks it's necessary then it
should be done this way in terms of
protection of civilians I know some
people in Donetsk and luhansk and I know
how they used to live these people want
to help them
let's have a look at what else is going
in on in Moscow then with a journalist
at Natalie uh small excuse me Natalie
smallen Silver uh welcome to DW at
Natalie is this making the news there in
Moscow today
yes absolutely in all the major TV
channels and news Publications this is
the only topic people are talking about
importantly how are the Russian media
reporting about this topic because the
narrative that has been presented here
drastically differs from The Narrative
we are talking about the DW news for
example and in the main Russian channels
this is portrayed not as war or Invasion
or occupation even it is portrayed as
the military operation with the goal of
freeing the Ukraine from its current
regime and protecting the people there
and the people buying that is is that
the message that that Russians are
taking from this
well this message
has been a lot of preparation for this
uh for this message and for this moment
they've been ongoing propaganda campaign
on Russian State TV for for months and
for days now
um that's why a lot of people in Russia
are confused right now what to feel and
how to feel about this and we've seen in
the in the report from the streets of
Moscow that people are very divided
um there haven't been a strong support
for
um for recognizing of so-called luhans
and donets people Republic only about 45
of Russian population according to
Independent
um levada Center all are supporting this
decision of Putin and we don't know yet
how how many people are supporting the
this Invasion but
um people are in shock and they are
obviously not not ready have not been
ready to see what's happening now right
so so whatever the story is that the
President Putin is giving them this does
not sound like the Russian people are
ready to lose their sons and their
husbands in a war over Ukraine
yes a lot of
a lot of them know what to think
you think are going out to the streets
to protest and they're saying they don't
even hope that something will change
because they don't know how else how can
they affect the decisions in Kremlin but
many people on the streets have been
telling my colleagues that they cannot
just not go out they don't know what
else to do and they've been protests in
Russian cities all across Russia right
now in Moscow there are several a
hundred people on on the street it's
really hard to estimate how many because
they've been detained all the time and
right now according to the last
information around 600 people have been
detained in this protest all over Russia
right and these are protests calling for
what
so the protesters are calling for no war
they don't have any other political
demands yet they are
um not shouting even sometimes calling
sometimes shouting sometimes just just
bringing flowers to the protest they
don't even some have some um something
written on their banners like nowhere in
Ukraine or just no war or some are just
there because they are afraid of
speaking up publicly because
um the price of this can be very
expensive
right I I but this is one of the things
that that has most impressed me about
what you said there that the idea that
hundreds of people would take to the
streets in a country where even one
person carrying a placard can be
arrested very so clearly they feel very
strongly about this
yes exactly
um a lot of people are feeling very
strongly about it because
um they have been living in this
situation for uh for a long time the
risk the conflict how how it's portrayed
here have been there since 2014 and
um I think
um or I have a feeling that no one
expected this to escalate so quickly
until that extent a lot of people on
social media expressed their
um their grievances their fears their
shock their sadness in this moment and a
lot of also prominent Russians um not
collisions but
um actresses and journalists and even
even TV presenters from the um from the
state TV um are saying on their social
media that they are feeling really
strongly about it they're ashamed and
they are don't support this decision and
they don't support the war
thank you so much for for joining us and
painting us that picture of life in
Moscow at the moment Natalie Natalie a
small and Savor journalist thank you
has had the opportunity to speak to uh
rather if Keith Vetter he's a member of
the German Parliament for the opposition
Christian democrats and sits on the
Parliamentary of Foreign Affairs
committee the scenario that everyone
feared has now happened what was your
response what were your thoughts when
you heard the news Well I wasn't
surprised I only was surprised by the
effectiveness and speed he did this
because in June last year already he
announced Turi or to integrate not to
reintegrate Ukraine to Russia and has
denied the right of existence of Ukraine
so all the effort from the western side
since 2008 to avoid the membership of
Ukraine and NATO or to arm since 2040 to
arm the Ukraine were taken from Putin as
a sign of weakness and therefore
we should read very carefully what he
has uttered and edited the last months
and years
we reluctant
and is that something that
should now and will now change
well I'm in the minority I have asked
for a selective support with weapons air
defense for example
measures to protect borders anti-tank
missiles and others but also Jammers
against I.T infrastructure and signal
nevertheless I believe that our position
will not change I believe that will we
will or might support others to export
weapons but our armed forces are so weak
not able to export or to bring over the
borders any of the weapon systems so we
also should reassure ourselves that if
we want to have a deterrent Force then
we must invest much more into our Armed
Forces than in the past do you think
further sanctions will have any effect
no they will not have any effect on his
plan to occupy Ukraine to integrate
Ukraine and probably will have no effect
on inserting incubating uh Belarus into
Russia and will not have any effect to
destroy transnistria or to destroy the
right of existence of molavia so we are
at the beginning of a huge change of the
landscape of the map of Eastern Europe
so what can Europe what can Germany
specifically do to try and avoid that
scenario we will not avoid it because
nobody is willing to have War but what
we could do is to affect the lines of
communication of Putin and to destroy
the reliability of his population so
this population is suffering from spare
Goods is suffering from a weak
infrastructure is suffering from
participation
and we see also your broadcast is not
available to be present in Russia any
longer but I believe in the power of
democracy and Putin has is in fear of
democracy and freedom what we should
expect is that we need patience we need
an enduring effort for the next years
and Putin does not believe that we have
the power to be patient
you're watching that DW news live from
Berlin let me recap our top story our
only story of the day Russia has
launched a full-scale invasion of
Ukraine with attacks being carried out
by air and land forces across the
country Kiev says dozens have been
killed and many injured in an assault
that NATO says amounts to a cold-blooded
Invasion Western leaders say they will
impose crippling sanctions as thousands
of ukrainians scramble to leave the
biggest cities
let's catch you up with uh your business
news then
hi Christine what have you got for us
right uh will we have a
update coming up for you uh just a
moment here
so the knock-on effect of Russia's
invasion is being felt around the world
U.S stocks declined at the market open
after European markets closed in the red
and with some indices losing more than
five percent
Asian markets dropped by around 3
percent
safe havens are in high demand with the
price of gold up by almost two percent
its highest level in more than a year
other news in the economic Fallout of
Russia's invasion of Ukraine include
the price of Brent crude which has
topped 100 a barrel for the first time
in seven years
the Russian Ruble has fallen to a new
low against the U.S dollar
and meanwhile Germany says it will boost
its Cyber attack defense amid the
invasion in Ukraine and Ukraine has
closed its airspace to civilian flights
due to the high safety risk
the effects of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine are being felt at home as well
of course let's take a closer look at
exactly how markets reacted
Russian markets collapse so swiftly
Thursday that trading had to be halted
markets are back up and running now but
the mood is still somber
Russia's attack on Ukraine has spooked
investors all around the world
we're seeing the classic patterns of the
market gold goes up government bonds go
up oil gas is going up even more and
what goes down are the equity markets
with the uncertainty of what happens
next the opinion is still that there
will not be a large-scale military
conflict involving NATO
oil prices have already jumped above a
hundred dollars a barrel the highest
level since 2014. that's when Russia
annexed Crimea
how much further crude will rise will
depend on if Russia's energy exports are
hit by Western sanctions
I think for prices actually to increase
it's not only the actual fact happening
but really the expectation that it might
happen might be enough to actually
increase the oil price on the global
market I mean Russia is the second
biggest exporter of oil
Traders are hanging on every move from
the Kremlin now how International
markets trade in the coming days will
depend on the course of war in Ukraine
and the effects of Western sanctions
well Russians are worried about their
savings as the ruble loses value against
the dollar
the currency could fall even further if
Russia is excluded from the Global
Payments Swift system
across Russia are lining up to withdraw
their savings and exchange them for US
dollars or Euros that's after the value
of the Russian Ruble plunged to a record
low banks in Moscow are charging 100
rubles for one US dollar a week ago it
cost only 75 rubles
Russia's Central Bank has been
intervening in the currency Market to
try and stabilize the ruble while also
providing support to financial
institutions
no one knows what's going to happen with
the currency with our economy and it's
not clear if we're able to survive the
crisis like in 2014 or our situation
will only get worse
2014 was when Russia annexed Crimea and
was hit by a slew of sanctions from the
West This Time Financial penalties could
hit harder some want Russia excluded
from the global payment system Swift
swift is how most Russian Banks send
money in and out of the country without
it Russia's trade with the world would
grind to a halt
the most severe sanctions such as
cutting Russia off from the global Swift
payment system or excluding Russian
Banks from the Global Financial Market
would endanger Russia's uh energy
exports to Europe and also other exports
where Russia is a significant supplier
such as industrial materials like nickel
copper Etc so far the West has decided
not to pull that lever blocking ration
gas or raw materials deliveries could
rickal shape back on Western Powers
through higher prices and bottlenecks
uh the Kremlin may be banking on some
resistance therefore from European
governments to go that far because they
would be also impacted if the energy
exports were disrupted but there is no
certainty that the kremlin's BET will
pay off in any case the cost of War will
be high for Moscow economists assume
that the war will drive the country into
a deep recession and worsen the standard
of living for all Russians
and that's all from this special
business update on how Russia's
unfolding invasion of Ukraine is
affecting financial markets now back to
Phil Gale with the latest news
developments thank you so much for that
and yes of course this is the big story
of the day the only one we're covering
at the moment Russia's invasion of
Ukraine DW correspondent funny for sure
is in Kiev and sent us this
just before I've been hearing once again
Sirens blaring their food that quite
often today in fact for the very first
time shortly after the first explosion
hit here around 4 a.m or shortly after
Vladimir Putin declared quote a military
operation against Ukraine now that
military operation actually turns into a
full-scale Invasion several Rockets had
hit various cities an invasion by land
by air by sea that is what is happening
right now in Ukraine and people here and
Keith the ones who are staying are
hoping that maybe what we have
experienced this morning the explosions
the shelling that maybe this is it but
if you ask me there have been so many
things happening over the course of the
past days that nobody thought is likely
and turned out to be real politic for
example the recognition of the two
self-proclaimed states in the donbass
region luhansk and donets that have been
uh that have been basically taken as a
declared as excuse me as an independent
region and also Vladimir Putin is saying
that basically Ukraine doesn't have the
right to exist as a state so that
clearly signals that unfortunately more
likely more is to come even though at
this point things seem to be calm behind
me we
have seen a lot of Ukrainian Security
Forces we cannot independently verify
actually what those uh shellings or what
those explosions have hit but there are
reports that the military airport just
50 kilometers from here was also
attacked as well as a a building which
is supposedly the military intelligence
headquarters that's DW correspondent
funny Fisher in Ikea let's find out more
about the EU reaction then with DW's
Brussels bureau chief Alexandra Von
Norman welcome Alexandra so let's let's
talk about what EU leaders have been
saying today
well we expect the European leaders to
arrive here shortly and they are coming
together to discuss further measures
against Russia sanctions but so far many
leaders expressed their
um their feelings also and we expect
this actually to be a quite emotional
Summit also according to EU officials
that we have been speaking with the
European commission president ozola from
The Lion spoke of dark hours in Europe
she condemned Russia's unprecedented and
unjustified attack on Ukraine those two
words were heard here repeatedly today
the French President Emmanuel Macomb for
instance said that this is a turning
point point in history of Europe and the
German Chancellor Olaf scholz who was
also speaking of a Dark Hour in Europe
up assessed that the Russian President
Vladimir Putin is trying to turn back
time in Europe right and as they meet to
talk about sanctions if I'm right this
this will be the third set of Sanchez
the EU has had sanctions against Russia
uh for months even years they agreed
another set and then this happened
um if you look at the track record the
the use of sanctions doesn't look
particularly effective what is this
latest set likely to look like
well you're right that it seems that
Vladimir Putin doesn't care at all about
sanctions and consequences but the
European leaders had made it clear
before that they are determined to
impose massive and severe sanctions
against Russia sanctions that will erode
Russia's industrial Base According to
European commission president ozula
thunderline what is on the table are
sanctions against whole sectors of
Russia's economy the transport sector
Financial market for the lion stressed
at that
companies will not be able to borrow
money on you on International markets
and there is more to come
all right thank you for that DW's
Brussels bureau chief Alexandra afan
Norman you're watching at DW stay tuned
for our continuing coverage of Russians
war against Ukraine
[Music]